лопати побачиш його which are віза в
монетарну допомогу це пітер зовсім нами
не
нападу на яких ідея наук сподівання
сепаратистами території самої з 40
секундне відео amnesty international
прибрала для ілюстрації ситуації із правом
і людей на в Україні починай хіба що
справно часті на українську на салоні в
зоні бойових дій джек право запасних
і там на ідея закон на мої рясні
преси асс апарат їсть видаються дока ту
війну проти конфлікту проросійські
сепаратисти групу пару cheval та права
людини винив channel і весь пощастило чини
на прокладку бував і за ручники повз нього
адже серйозніше підтвердження туди крим
2014 руку куб і вал росія на пиво
стравив ближче не права і свободи на
самовираження збір це об'єднує ці
розвитку з людьми з проукраїнськими
шкоди ми сувора розправляєте
криму 9 нині російські закони з
означає що там права та свободи вали
кенобі спати і там дуже важко
організовувати та massave заходи рахунок не
постраждати і заточені під ремствування та
повітовий цу особливо дискримінації
усвідомлюєте кримські татари у team проблеми
з правом і крижані малюка на
окупованих територіях України
призначають звив правозахисники вимагає
вид криво по карате в інших у скронь їх
злачних з українського боку
amnesty international так вже критикуючи
україну повели на розслідування
закрут у прато євромайдану
сподіваюся на тисячу саду почуття в Україні
стани на закладеному правозахиснику ще
моїх або обидва хну і не україна вони
говорять ми з поста revo йому в україні по
приборканню важливі ви прахлад щодо давно
у хвала на і закон гвинт стаю ще
видно не будуть ворон вона закладена
інстанція я до досліджених закруту
соломи kill
це дуже важливо коло перекласти кашляти
amnesty international сп одягається ще
назвеш на бюро розслідувань і знову
там і малюка на парі
і шкіряних силових че чиновник
побачити і ми за законом